is this the first time there's been not
there's not been an Omnibus or a CR in
what decades or yeah I mean this is the
first time since I think 1997. you can
check me on that but but but but to get
that here's what we have to avoid so one
of the one of the bizarre rules of the
house is if you ever have 218 signatures
on any piece of legislation it's do not
pass go do not collect 200 that
legislation goes directly to the floor
so all 213 Democrats are willing to sign
what's called a clean continuing
resolution which is no changes to the
government keep funding the woke
weaponized government why wouldn't they
this was the deal that McConnell and
Pelosi initially made they'd continue
that forever under under those terms so
they've got a clean CR and what the
threat is is that five uh you know
liberal or moderate Republicans could
just say we don't want to do the single
subject bills we don't want to go
through the pain of doing the cuts to
foreign aid or the food stamps or
anything like that